welcome um I'm Jacqueline goldsby I
teach English and African-American
studies and I've been uh the happy
camper um at the series of lectures that
has brought us all here together tonight
the Frankie lectures in the humanities
and since this marks our last um event
for what's been a really invigorating
season
and uh punctuated by real world events
that have made me understand just why
James Ballwin matters um to the time we
live in uh I want to give thanks to uh
several uh collaborators who've made
this work possible first of all I want
to thank the Whitney Humanity Center its
director and staff uh the director Gary
Tomlinson of the staff members uh Sandra
Ma and Bs who were very uh supportive in
and I and I want to say this um bending
the rules a bit so that we could um hold
these lectures in the evening so that
anybody and everybody who could make it
here could attend um these lectures are
typically held at 4:00 in the afternoon
um and it was uh uh a productive
discussion to decide to hold them at
5:30 and I'm glad that the um that the
staff was willing to do that and I thank
um what that I'm I'm grateful for what
that meant in terms of the building
staff to be here longer than they
expected and and I want to give thanks
as always to Tony sudall and tonight's
technical crew for making our sound and
visuals possible I also want to thank
Phoenix Alexander who's been my graduate
assistant organizing these lectures
throughout the semester this has
required an enormous amount of work
behind the scenes that um to make the
evenings go seamlessly and I want to
thank Phoenix for your thank you so much
um and I also want to thank our donors
uh Barbara and Richard Frankie who've
attended quite a few of the events um
luckily they live here in New Haven um
but they would show up and think with us
and were nothing but supportive of the
kinds of questions that we wanted to
raise um and as I said in my first at
our first uh event um
you know this is this is what we get to
do in a place like this we get to teach
at scale and I'm really grateful for the
support that they provided for us to
think that way together I also want to
thank you all for coming there's some
people here who've been coming every
week and I I notice you I see you thank
you so much for making the time and I
also want to thank my students um in the
course that accompanies that really
supports what we're doing James belt
balwins American scene I have 18 Terri
rically talented devoted tireless
students um who've really worked hard
and thought hard these last 15 weeks or
so um and on evenings like this our day
together starts at around 2:30 and goes
until about 10 so sometimes not tonight
because this is the final weeks of class
so I want to thank you all for your
dedication and commitment to the class
thank you
um one of the
points that's been really striking to me
if you were here um for our screening of
Raul PEX I am not your negro um on
November 18th I believe that was um
reading through Baldwin's Cannon there
certain words that come up a
lot constantly
consistently the price paying one's dues
right what are the obligations of being
a citizen in in this country we have
dues to pay um and not the complaint
that we hear about taxes but moral dues
to pay to one another and that's a term
a concept that comes up consistently in
his work um
countrymen one one word of his that
comes up constantly that word countrymen
has actually kept me grounded in these
weeks since the election because uh
Ballwin reminds me over and over again
that America is mine too America is ours
too and um if we are willing to struggle
and to fight for freedom and for
Democratic principles then we can call
ourselves countrymen to one
another one of the debates we've had in
our class though um Baldwin's
relationship to feminism where do women
fit in the picture that's been harder
and Elusive to
track and I don't know that I have an
answer for that um
and I wonder if it might come to us
though there are other terms that he
uses and evokes constantly in his work
being
naked being naked being honest being
open being fully present in all that we
do not being afraid of what Audrey Lord
would call the powers of the
erotic right to make us honest
countrymen and women with one
another Balwin fearlessly confronted the
nword
right and one of the lessons that I've
learned uh reading his work this whole
term was the critical distance the way
in which he could position himself apart
from that term and take it apart
deconstruct it so that he wasn't defined
by it but knew the power that it had to
organize our world that concept of
dehumanizing a thingify black people and
other people of
color the the word we're going to look
at tonight with our speaker tonight um
is is a term that's constantly evoked
about Baldwin it's R throughout all of
his literature in all of its forms the
essays the novels the short stories the
dramas
love
love I'll say that with the um Raul peek
film I was stri I was struck that love
was not an organizing keyword in it but
I would argue that it's actually Central
to appreciating the force of Baldwin's
Artistry Baldwin's politics Baldwin's
commitment love and our speaker tonight
will help us understand what that term
means Chris LeBron is assistant
professor of African-American studies
and philosophy here at Yale he is the
author of the color shame race and
Justice in our time published by Oxford
University press and it was the winner
of the American political science
Association foundations of political
Theory first book award he is the author
of numerous academic articles and book
reviews on race and political ethics and
you might know him best through his
public writing where he seems to almost
have a near permanent perch I'm glad to
say um in the New York times's stone
column as well as the Boston Review he's
just completed a brief intellectual
history of the idea black lives matter
in that book the making of black lives
matter a brief history of an idea will
be published by Oxford University press
in Spring of
2017 he was also recently named a
finalist for the Pyatt prize awarded by
the Dallas Institute for humanities and
culture which recognizes promising young
scholars and writers who are influencing
public debates through their writing and
if and I really would invite you to to
go to the New York Times website and um
you can either Google Chris LeBron New
York Times you'll find a whole string of
Articles and those articles are not only
penetrating for their commentary on our
present political Strife but I really
appreciate the ways in which Chris tries
really works at doing philosophy in
public and for the public and it's that
intelligence that he'll bring to our
work tonight of thinking about Baldwin
and love so welcome to to Chris
[Music]
br I've always said welcome to Yale for
our speakers but you're here at Yale so
so welcome down the block
[Music]
that's good evening can everyone
everyone hear me okay um thank you all
for for joining joining us this evening
um it's the end of the semester it's
December the holidays around the corner
people are exhausted from the regular
work of the year right it's also the end
the of the calendar year we're also
exhausted for other political reasons
and sometimes it seems as if American
Life Bears down on us and I think it's
really important when we can come
together and in some sense recollect
ourselves intellectually to rejuvenate
our sense of belonging in American
society especially when some of us feel
as if we're being pushed increasingly to
the margin for that I want to thank Dr
goldby for inviting me to this important
lecture series there is no doubt that
James baldon has always been important
for America but I think Dr goldby is
absolutely right that he is especially
important for us now I want to thank the
Whitney Humanity Center for hosting this
series of lectures and again thank you
for joining me I want to in some sense
apologize up front I typically don't
read presentations when I give my talks
um but there are a number of things I
want to do tonight that I want to try to
do as precisely as can be done um and so
so in that sense for that reason I will
present the lecture more formally but
during Q&A um we will loosen up a bit so
please bear with me in the more kind of
formal presentation of the ideas
tonight it seems to me that we as a
nation are in real trouble I'll be
forgiven I hope for making what seems to
me an entirely uncontroversial remark
when I say that the fight we face is not
one between the left and the right
between socialists and free market
Advocates between progressives and
conservatives sure these tags and labels
are meaningful to some people and every
once in a while they are meaningful with
good
reason but the real fight we face is
between decency and
indecency when I use the word decent I
don't mean to invoke Victorian
sensibility about proper appearances and
manners I mean it rather in a heavy
moral sense
the decent person is one who thinks
other people's suffering is worth paying
attention to grounds for action and a
check on self-interest the decent person
thinks respect for others comes before
privileged racial
identity the decent person for the
decent person common humanity is the
organizing moral framework for deciding
how to act in the world decency doesn't
guarantee agreement that would be a
boring World in any case but decency
does something else that is crucial it
preempts the kind of sociopolitical
clumsiness that exhibits itself as
cruelty decency Keeps Us Tethered to a
sense of being at least partially
responsible for other people's
well-being even when they don't think
look or Live Like Us America is failing
quite consistently at being a racially
decent Society this is why we are in so
much trouble over the past months the
2016 Frankie lectures have centered our
Collective attention on James Baldwin
one of America's most formidable
thinkers and writers you have heard
Baldwin discussed within the context of
queerness music and film my walk with
Baldwin today will be different today I
treat him as a political philosopher
whose writings are all too timely in
helping us think about what it would
take to achieve a decent Society marked
by racial Justice baldwi wants us to
think long and hard about who we are in
relation to the promising ideal of a
society excuse me of a society that
respects every person's right to
flourish he wants us to think carefully
about this ideal given that for us it is
positioned against the backdrop of a
white supremacist history and
founding balton's writings have so much
to say about the underpinning of
democratic Ethics in ways that have yet
to be philosophically appreciated they
allow us to ask familiar questions in
new philosophical ways ways here is the
main thing I've been thinking
about Bolton urges us to an ethics of
love the question I want to address is
not about how to love or who to love at
least not
primarily rather I want to think through
with you this evening why why should we
love at all why should we commit to an
idea that requires sacrifice in a world
in a society that already take so much
from Black
Americans as I read Baldwin the ansers
that love is a requirement of social
justice in Democratic
Society during my time with you this
evening I want to explore this line of
thought through an engagement I staged
between James Baldwin and John rolls
rolls is widely considered the most
important political philosopher of the
20th century rs's importance to my field
hinges on his Monumental work a theory
of Justice a philosophical Masterwork
describing the ideally just
Society one of the most interesting
ideas and roles is something he called
the strains of commitment I'll describe
the idea more in just a while but has to
do with the pressures everyday citizens
must endure in the course of upholding
and maintaining a just Society my
argument today is that love can play a
crucial role in helping us all endure
the strains of commitment Baldwin saw
this role
clearly thus the purpose of the work
I'll be pursuing in the coming months is
to add balton's importance to a field of
study political thought that sees him
acknowledge him but does not accept him
as one of its own the work in this
lecture is for me highly preliminary a
first step on a road to a more extended
project most of what I draw on in
Baldwin will come from a very limited
set of resources but that is My
Prerogative as a philosopher to reliably
identify the core of a system of thought
upon which something truly useful can be
built and at the core of Baldwin is
something not only beautiful and
stirring but democratically useful and
urgent to get to it we first begin with
John
rolls I have a story I like to tell
about John rolls it is an imagined story
that is entirely
plausible it is 1963 a year before the
Civil Rights Act has been passed and
while in the midst of thinking through
the arguments that would inform his
important philosophy of contractual
agreement Ral is sitting in front of his
television watching Birmingham police at
B Conor command set upon nonviolent
protesters with dogs and fire hoses and
he is thinking something democratically
essential how on Earth could people with
severely distinct interest ever
collectively share in the benefits of a
well-ordered
democracy his work the theory Justice is
an attempt to answer this question in
the abstract there are two components to
rolls his work one concerns his
methodology with which need not
preoccupy us tonight the other component
has to do with ideas Central to how we
get to thinking about a just society and
these are interesting for us the first
idea is that of a social contract that
is the regulating background agreement
to which we are all a party in living in
the society we do in this tradition of
thought what is Paramount is a
democratic aspiration that shared social
norms and structures of authority are
collectively
legitimized the next important idea is
that all persons have a sense of Justice
this is not a claim that all people are
just rather that all people have some
idea of justice that it is capable of
informing their character and how we
dispose ourselves to what Justice
requires what needs to be done is to
shape this capacity to think rightly
about Justice into a reliable skill RS
writes quote a conception of Justice
characterizes our moral sensibility when
the everyday judgments we do make are in
accordance with its principles we do not
understand our sense of justice until we
know in some systematic way covering a
wide range of cases what these
principles are in other words our sense
of justice effectively depends on the
relationship between the division of
Justice to which we agree and the
everyday ways in which we act here is a
crucial part Ro further says says quote
a theory of justice is a theory of the
moral sentiments setting out the
principles govern our moral powers or
more specifically our sense of justice
end quote and this leads to the third
thing that is important to know and
opens the door for Baldwin I'll
explain it isn't enough that we merely
come to an agreement on what a good
Society requires we have to be prepared
to live by that agreement on an ongoing
basis my motivating thought is that we
today share on a Democratic Society that
is fundamentally built on the notion of
equality of Liberty and rights but many
many Americans seem resistant to
thinking about this about how to abide
by what equality requires of us
especially Racial equality RS tried to
address this kind of Problem by
stipulating condition he termed the
strains of commitment which is a
philosophical way of saying the
following if you were being reasonable
and sincere when you made an agreement
nothing can release you from living by
it certainly not a change in attitude or
social tastes being able to endure the
strains of commitment is what allow ows
us to maintain and perpetuate a good
Society characterized by
Justice with the radical material
inequality between whites and blacks and
the lopsidedness of the justice system
in addition to what strikes so many of
us as a routine elimination of black
bodies by the police there is very
little sense that Americans white
Americans and institutions that
privilege them are reliably operating
under any strains of commitment let us
now recall that Ro says we each have a
sense of justice and that this sense is
a capacity rather than a skill that is
already fully formed this means there is
room for it to properly develop and let
us also recall that he says a theory of
justice is a theory of the moral
sentiments this allows us to ask is
there a moral sentiment that could help
support our sense of justice under the
strains of commitment the answer I offer
you tonight is that love is one such
moral sentiment and that James Balden
offers a powerful way of thinking and
help us think about the role love can
play in a just
democracy part
two on why we should love white
Americans we are asking today why should
we love listen to Baldwin quote the
unexamined life is not worth living the
despair among the Loveless is that they
must narcotize themselves before they
can touch any human being at all they
then fatally touch the wrong person not
merely because they have gone blind or
have lost their sense of touch but
because they no longer have any way of
knowing that a lovess touch is a
violation end
quote according to Baldwin many things
are alarming about the Loveless person
the proximity of another person is so
vivid that the Loveless must numb their
sensibilities when they do accept
proximity they commit an offensive act
because they do not know how to come
close to me without violating me they
are fact making a mistake as to who I am
in relation to them that is I am a
person owed genuine thoughtful
conscientious love there's of course a
way to read baldon's passage as
unabashedly sensualist in a
straightforward way but baldon was what
I would call a democratic sensualist
sensualist for him American democracy is
a way of arranging intimate public lives
and invite sharing investigation
affection and mutual
vulnerability the primary crime in
America for Baldwin is that our shared
history of white supremacy has rendered
blacks Untouchable to white but
something else has happened it has
rendered whites themselves as unable to
appreciate the depth of their own
Humanity has numbed them to the promise
of intimacy this is what for Baldwin
makes them Loveless the cycle then
becomes tragic where the historically
oppressed are the victims of those who
are self- victimizing and this makes us
wonder how to cycle can be
broken an important key to this puzzle
can be found in baldon's letter to his
nephew my dungeon shook which serves as
a preface to the fire next time
Baldwin's letter starts off with a very
Stark and commanding instructional
warning Baldwin long lamented what he
might describe as a wretchedness of his
father's life and was wretched in a very
tragic sense as baldon tells his nephew
regarding his father quote well he is
dead he never saw you and he had a
terrible life he was defeated long
before he died because at the bottom of
his heart he really believed what white
people said about him end
quote one way to read Baldwin's
criticism as his father is as a
psychological argument familiar to
anyone who has read du boys wherein the
concern is that the internalization by
blacks of white America's perceptions of
blacks is a sure road to self erosion
but another closely related way to read
Baldwin here is as posing a fundamental
ethical criticism of the following
sort once we see the ground of
self-esteem and self-worth then we
cannot hold back the pressures and
vagaries of contempt and belittlement
directed towards us thus blacks give up
the only thing we ever truly possess our
humanity and giving that up is a
violation of the self blacks' law of
Humanity on account of racism is for
Baldwin the ultimate defeat which is why
Baldwin instructs his nephew as follows
quote there is no reason for you to try
to become like white people and there is
no reason no basis whatever for their
impertinent assumption that they must
accept you end quote the problem as
baldon sees it is that there is unequal
power in
America white Americans possess
narrative capabilities that have real
effects they're able to tell and express
a story about Black Americans that is
assumed to be the definitive story of
course starring ideas like deviants
criminality licentiousness and laziness
it's not an affirming story after all
baldon's father died from believing what
white people said about him now
depending on your own disposition you
might think the natural reaction to the
effects and practices of this imbalance
of power is resentment but Baldwin's
counsel to his nephew is quite the
opposite quote the really terrible thing
old buddy is that you must accept them
and I mean that very seriously L you
must accept them with love for these
innocent people have no other hope end
quote recall our question is why does
Baldwin counsel us to love my position
is that love is part of what is required
in a just democracy I have suggested
following roles that in a society
governed by a political system defined
by Collective ascent and
legitimization Citizens need to not only
agree to adjust his demands but be able
to uphold and live by those demands the
important difficulty he that Justice
often requires sacrifice even as our
everyday lives introduce lapses into
biases of judgment and lazy attitudes
that run counter to abiding what Justice
demands of us which is why abiding by
what Justice requires is what RS calls a
strain of commitment but since our
capacity to abide by what Justice
mandates depends on the moral sentiments
I have been supposing there is a moral
sentiment that is crucially helpful in
sustaining the strain of affirming and
supporting a just Society I am claiming
that one such sentiment is love and that
Baldwin gives us an important clue as to
how that is the case in counseling his
nephew to love rather than resent and by
identifying whites as Innocents we now
have traction on the puzzle allow me to
explain in a book I have just written on
the idea of black lives matter I argue
that balin's brand of Love is consistent
with what the ancient Greeks called
filia love as compared to Eros sexual
love on the one hand or Agape
disinterested love on the other filia
love is a love we show
kin the kind of love we show kin is in
some sense the most demanding and
enduring it presumes equality of shared
concerns and it presupposes the ability
to demand recognition it helps us
perceive others as accountable thus
making thus makes holding them
accountable and this is a really crucial
part as part of loving them rather than
as accusing for the sake of
Retribution when we are a brothers and
sisters keeper we hold two things close
to ourselves the right to demand the
obligation to give when what is our
right to demand is betrayed we respect
that person by support by supposing they
are capable of responding to moral
demands when we act as we are obligated
we respect that person as being a
legitimate source of claims when we fail
to act as we are obligated we make
ourselves susceptible to being held
accountable boldness commitment to filia
then is grounded in a very Democratic
ethos it is a disposition that reaches
for the egalitarian sensibility of equal
and mutual concern voice and shared
habits for example in a 1965 debate with
William Buckley baldwi makes this
unexpected claim quote we talk about
integration in America as though it were
some great new conundrum the problem in
America is that we've been integrated a
very long time put me next to any
African and you will see what I mean end
quote bolon asserts this in the context
of laying claim to his fellow Americans
by saying that when he sees his
countryman overseas only he and the
other American truly understand each
other sharing the same sociopolitical
shorthand as they do this is an
important claim for it is polit for it
politically encloses Baldwin with white
Americans rather than drawing a line
down the middle according to racial
experience despite the power and
balances of which baldon was all too
aware Baldwin stance affirms the idea
that once concerns are voice between
Democratic co-participants even when the
relationship is marked by Injustice it
is incumbent upon each of us to consider
those concerns while being ready to
respond I should say at this point that
the argument here is not that any voice
concern is one that obligates others
surely some concerns are trivial or
offensive the argument rather is
thematic in identifying the kind of
status we should hold in each other's
eyes the status of political
kin so if filia hinges in part on
holding each other accountable why then
does Baldwin refer to whites as
Innocents this line can sit
uncomfortably as a way of letting white
Americans off the hook on account of the
way they victimize themselves but this
is is quite the opposite of what Baldwin
intends when Baldwin refers to white
Americans as innocent he in a sense
means that term in the way we speak
about small children being innocent
because they do not know enough about
the world to fully appreciate their
culpability when they do wrong things
yet not being in the best position to
appreciate one's culpability is not the
same as Absolution for as baldman also
says to his nephew quote but it is not
permissible that the auths of
devastation ation should also be
innocent it is the Innocence which
constitutes the crime end quote and this
statement in many ways encapsulates one
very important aspect of the role love
and justice for Baldwin notice that in
counseling his nephew to love Bolden
recommends first that his nephew secure
his independent sense of worth and then
he ought to embrace whites while doing
so his nephew should in the immediate
sense recognize the kind of innocence in
whites being causally aloof from history
yet this causal alness does nothing to
redeem moral culpability being the
authors of Devastation while clinging to
causal aloofness is the great crime I
think then that for Baldwin the role
love is meant to play among kin is to
hold the culpable to account without
mere accusation to demand without
berating in doing so one brings white
Americans into the proper relationship
with how racial history racial identity
and privilege converge on on black lives
to impose disadvantage and often
suffering in coming into a right
relationship with this convergence
Baldwin I think supposes whites are
better positioned to hold up their end
at a democratic deal for the long term
to endure their strains of commitment
for it is certain that as Balin sees it
they are in no position to do so
now part three on why black Americans
need to love
themselves
quote perhaps we were all of us pimps
racketeers church members and
children bound together by the nature of
our oppression the specific and peculiar
complex of risks we had to run if so
Within These limits we sometimes
achieved with each other a freedom that
was close to love end
quote Baldwin spent a brief span of his
mid- teenage years in a Pulpit of the
church attending to Black
spirituality his initiated encounter was
was at Mount Calvary of the Pentecostal
Faith with Bishop Rosa Artemis horn who
asked at that first meeting whose little
boy are you balon's biographer David
Leeming recalls for us quote bolon was
struck later by the fact that exactly
that same question had been asked by by
pimps and racketeers who wanted to hang
out with him baldon wondered whether the
church wasn't one more hustle and
environment built on a harmful falseness
to our own capacities to sympathy
for example quote I really mean that
there was no love in the church it was a
mask for hatred and self-hatred and
despair end quote for Baldwin the place
of safe congregation propagated of
complex of beliefs perceptions and
attitudes that were antithetical to the
very idea of Salvation in a stirring
passage from his autobiographical novel
go tell on the mountain balen describes
the transformation of congregants in a
black church as they worship in
Jubilation quote something happened to
their faces and their voices the rhythm
of their bodies and to the air they
breathed his father's face always awful
became more awful his father's daily
anguish transformed into prophetic wrath
end quote that balen situation concerns
within the framework of religious
worship is not entirely to the point
baldon's deeper concern was that the
church was a conduit for something that
was already endemic to Black life the
powerful inducement to self- negation
and despair imposed by white SU
one of the powerful roles of love for
Bolden then isn't only the ways blacks
love of whites might contribute to
whites getting into proper relationship
with Justice thus supporting their
ability to endure distrain of
commitment additionally black self-love
does a kind of work on The Souls of
black folks in which they can maintain
two important stances militant
resistance against disrespect and
marginalization alongside a largess of
heart to do the tough work of helping
cultivate democratic intimacy and
sensuality in our
society Baldwin however realized that
the flow of affect and rationality
between milit militancy and intimacy is
delicate and fought with pitfalls that
could corrupt our better
sensibilities this point cannot be
underestimated in the context of
thinking about pursuing a just Society
under the strains of commitment the aim
of seeking racial Justice is to undo
current regimes of marginalization and
oppression while instituting new habits
and modes of social cognition
in order to put in place a social scheme
in which blacks are properly
valued one main difficulty as I have put
it is that white Americans seem poorly
positioned to deal with what racial
Justice will necessarily ask of them I
have suggested following Baldwin that
Black's love for whites can help adjust
their frame of critical thinking in
order to abide by Justice even under the
strains of commitment but that isn't the
whole story the source of love for
others begins with the ability to love
ourselves we project the sincerity of
this moral sentiment successfully in so
far as we hold that moral sentiment with
regard to our own flourishing and
standing as persons owed
respect there are two places where
Baldwin very explicitly powerfully
grappled to the difficulties of
self-love note of a Native Son
represents an attempt by Baldwin to make
peace with his father's Legacy without
having to pay the price of inheriting a
destructive
patrimony as a parent in his address to
his nephew baldman clearly believed that
distinct from the awfulness of white
supremacy and racial inequality his
father had committed a crime against
himself and internalizing the awfulness
of white
supremacy this preoccupation baldon had
with his father's defeat wasn't a matter
of arguing an abstract principle or of
using his father as a practical example
the defeat of baldon's Father haunted
baldon because baldon felt and knew that
he was in no position to assume that he
was free from his father's patrimony the
main reason is that the sources that
defeat is bitterness and it is placed in
Blacks when they realize the nature of
the society they inhabit and the
struggle that Society imposes upon them
without any guarantee that those
struggles will be can be overcome here's
a point an example of the way in which
Balon was haunted quote I had discovered
the weight of white people in the world
I saw that this had been for my
ancestors and would now be for me an
awful thing to live with and that the
bitterness which had helped to kill my
father could also kill me end
quote the language of mortality here is
essential baldon's father had died while
suffering a very sharp mental decline
yes there were medical reasons for the
death of his father's body but the
causes of the death of his soul lay
squirely in the realm of the social and
personal he had believed white people
said about him thus he was defeated
before he died the acceptance of the
denigrating beliefs of racism had caused
a great bitterness that baldon was
determined to reject as his
patrimony but just as baldon was sure
the bitterness could be passed from
parent to child it could be passed
between other black folks who held each
other in
esteem consider the case of Richard
Wright Wright was one of the most
important novelists in the middle of
20th century and certainly one of the
most visible black novelists before I
even mention the title the book that has
likely come into your mind upon hearing
wri's name is Native Son
and the average American's quickness to
identify that book as an important black
novel was a real problem for Baldwin in
that book Wright was concerned to tell
the story of a black youth whose
depredations on account of his race
compelled him to a fit of rage and novel
in his fit of rage he commits murder and
rape Wright's own intent was to tell a
story so searing no white American could
turn away from it he hoped to burn into
the souls of his readers the effects of
the crimes of white supremacist
to warm them of the rage that was
brewing in Black
Americans the complication however was
twofold white readers missed wr's intent
and rather than reading the book as an
invitation to self-reflection they
tended to fetishize a story of a black
boy named bigger Thomas who commits
murder and rape out of rage and the book
was actually a book of the Month Club
selection
surprisingly but there was another thing
blacks were reading the book too and
they were read reading it as part of the
tradition of pro protest literature but
this would not do for baldwi on two
counts first he rejected the protest
novel as a helpful genre he writes in
everybody's protest novel quote but
unless one's ideal of society is a race
of neatly analyzed hardworking ciphers
one can hardly claim for the protest
novels the lofty purpose they claim for
themselves or share the present optimism
concerning them they emerge for what
they are a mirror of our confusion
dishonesty Panic tra Ed and mobilized in
the sunlet prison of the American dream
end quote the language of the mirror
here is so deeply
important mirrors show us only what we
show them no more no less and we only
see what's in the mirror when we look at
it this means mirrors are instruments of
convenient observation rather than tough
reflection moreover our acceptance that
a surface level image is an act of
self-deception as to the substance of
the image
beneath so when the protest novel merely
mirrors back to us our confusion
dishonesty and panic we may see it honor
it and even acknowledge it but all of
that ought to be just preliminary to the
tough work of ethical reflection and
political
action the offense then is that the
protest novel was on baldon's
observation taken as the end in itself
it's expressions of affect and complaint
were considered righteous and complete
rather than a starting point or wedge
for social change further and this is
baldon's second major point of concern
protest novels left those of us who
embrac them in a poor position to
conceive of ourselves as effective
thinking and feeling
agents consider boldin's specific
complaint against right's work quote for
bigger's tra tragedy is not that he is
cold or black or hungry but that he has
accepted a theology that denies him life
that he admits the possibility of his
being sub human and feels constrained
therefore to battle for his Humanity
according to those brutal criteria
bequeathed him at his birth this is the
key part but our humanity is our burden
our life we need not battle for it we
only to do what is infinitely more
difficult that is accept
it part four hope
aota
I began this lecture talking about
America's failure of decency it is time
to come back to that
idea on November 9th I woke to a
troubling reality the society that
continues to deal with the Echoes of
slavery that continues to exculpate
police and the shootings of unarmed
black Americans that has created food
deserts and urban centers that provides
unequal medical treatment by race that
fails to hire blacks for the same job as
whites despite the presentation of
identical resumés but they had at least
least at least elected a black American
for two terms as president had decided
to dial back the small amount of
progress the clock of American History
had been making an indecent thing was
done in handing the keys of immense
power to a person who actively
disrespects minorities and tells me that
I live in hell the indecency has
continued undebated with the appointment
of white of a white nationalist stre
Chief strategist and any number of known
racist and xenophobes taking part in the
presidential transition or floated as
possible members of the cabinet I would
feel democratically obligated to
apologize for ostensibly seem to partis
and comment at an event commit to open
discussion save that and I really must
say it this way my Democratic ethics
demand that I do save that what we face
isn't a matter of partisanship so much
as it is severe
indecency when we place white
nationalist and positions of strategic
strategic power in the white house we
have moved past policy disagreements to
AR
where Baseline morality that seeks to
express respect for all people is
offended Martin Frederick Ida Audrey
Malcolm are all
offended I highlight this in closing
because recent events rais deep
questions for us a remarkable feature of
the history of Black Thought is the
power of the idea that the problem with
America is not democracy but democracy's
practitioners and institutions they put
in place a common refrain in one strand
of Black Thought has been that the
forces of decency no matter their party
affiliation could take the day then
democracy could work as it was meant
with winners and losers in policy but
not in the chances for flourishing and
peaceably existing for these thinkers of
which Baldin was clearly one the idea of
democratic procedure and the ideals that
underwrite those procedures were one
source of
Hope however those ideals require
constant reaffirmation in the minds of
Americans This reaffirmation imposes
upon us all a kind of strain of
commitment and seeking social
justice many more white Americans than
do today must come to accept that
possession of privilege without
genuinely earning it is a great crime to
equality and liberty for
everyone blacks for their part face a
tough challenge we must simultaneously
hold in view the will to resist and the
duty to embrace it is this push and pull
of our affective and rational capacities
that has been our burden since America
landed on
us but it is what it is and we must
figure out how to get on with the
business of living of not being defeated
before dying there is work to be done to
bring more of our co-citizens into the
fold of decency when I think of this
work when I think how I can possibly do
it as exhausted as I am when I think of
what I am supposed to feel as I stretch
myself past reasonable limits
I am compelled to take comfort in the
Poetry of baldon's words and confidence
in their strident faith in humanity
quote the universe which is not merely
the stars and the moon and the planets
flowers grass and trees but other people
has evolved no terms for your existence
has made no room for you and if love
will not swing wide the gates no other
power will or
can peace and love to you this holiday
season thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
C
thank you very much um I I I think
you're spot on in your statements about
bodin's criticism of the of the church
to what extent do you think that his
ethics of Love however might have a
Biblical or a new testament texture or
basis to it that's an interesting
question thank you very much for it so
um my ability to answer you is limited
by the fact that I myself am not a
practitioner so I have I'm not I'm not
able to kind of get into specifics of
New Testament theology except for what I
know about it as a philosopher so I
could say is this I think Baldwin's
compel being compelled to love others by
their humanity is certainly con is
certainly consistent with Christian
theology for example right and in that
in that frame of thinking what matters
are two things one that other people are
sources of our compa are are sources of
claims that should elicit our compassion
and that our ability to respect
ourselves as sacred beings whether
divinely speaking or secularly speaking
our ability to respect ourselves as
sacred beings can only be honored and
the to the extent that we can express
that compassion to other like beings
right but then there's this aspect of
Baldwin that also right and you get this
clearly when he speaks about somebody
like sto stokeley carmichel or when he
gives Buckley a for boing about the
future where he thinks this is a kind of
social contractualist bent on this
Christian ideal that is look
I I I am obligated to love you as a
person who takes myself seriously as a
moral being but because I take myself
serious as a moral being there is a
limit at which the deal is off right so
when he says about stokeley listen I'm a
40-year-old black man stokeley is less
than 30 he doesn't want to live the life
that I lived and I cannot blame him for
that Baldwin's love was very complex
because he also show Stokely love as the
person that he is and realized that at
some Point people's claims for wanting
to be respected and non-marginalized
overrode some Universal abstract duty to
show everybody equal concern and he
thought that at some point there could
be a Breaking Point in which people will
have to choose a side because it will
become apparent that at some point our
loving others is actually a way of
disrespecting ourselves because it never
comes back to us
right
thank you very very much Chris I I'll
try and formulate this coherently but
you threw out so many powerful ideas I
mean I think the the challenge that
you've posed for us points to a a big
discrepancy because you know your talk
really brought home to me how cunning
and not innocent how purposeful Baldwin
strategy in the far next time is which
is to set up for us a model of a church
Church in which he had a a wouldbe
career founded on discourses of Love on
Christian appropriations of the
discourse of FIA uh and then to find it
severely wanting and to do that through
this language of sensuality which you
sketched out for us through Aeros
through the Flesh and the desires of the
flesh um and in doing so you know it
brought home to me Plato and political
thought how that's a very very clear
inversion and subversion of Plato's
ladder of Love which starts with the
erotic and the sensual and the carnal
and then transv values it into an
abstract
philosophical disinterest would be
disinterested love in which the erotic
power is there but kept in check by
harest higher forms but then the last
question about Christian filia actually
sort of clarified it for me in Greek
ancient Greek political Theory one of
the problems with filia is there's a
very small limit to the number of
friends you can have Phil you can have
in Aristotle's politics for example
whereas Christian New Testament
Appropriations ofilia say you can all be
friends a whole country can be friends
but then we've got patriotism lurking in
there as well with the sort
of deeply troubling make America great
again and the love that we're supposed
to feel for an abstraction that is in
all kinds of subtle ways uh racialized
and and encoded so you I think this is a
a really great project um but that it
throws into clarification lots of sort
of problems or complexities in trying to
think about love in political thought
more broadly and I appreciate it thank
you very much um you know what's
interesting about this idea you're
absolutely right about um this idea that
there's a question about how many people
you know are are in the right group for
loving and what's interesting about
Baldwin you know on the one hand we
think oh for him it's many many many
people because it's like all Americans
but I think From bolder's perspective
what's interesting is that he had a very
the idea of America was a very was a
very definitive circumscribing criteria
for who it was not that he didn't think
you love all Humanity right but I mean
it's it is shocking to hear him say put
me next to any African and you will see
what I mean and what Bal was cutting
against was the rising trend of kind of
like pan-africanism right and him saying
listen I don't have anything in common
with this African fellow like and so he
in some sense he denies that the color
of skin makes him closer to the African
it does this white man who's willing
who's ready to beat him right um but he
but this is the thing I find so
democratically powerful about Baldwin is
that he thinks because we've shared this
struggle as tragic as it is we are bound
together right um and there being bound
together something between me and this
Mississippi Man Who Would rather Club me
that's tighter than could be between me
and this African who has never done me
any wrong and looks like me but whom I
have no relationship and this is the
thing I'm kind of thinking through is
this work that the idea of the democracy
is doing and what's challenging my
boldwin is that I consider him a
political philosopher and actually a
fairly systematic political philosopher
but a person consider who was so who was
so interested in social justice he
actually has very little to explicitly
say about how democracies are formed the
structure of government the nature of
citizenship these are things po
philosophers usually take up he has he
has very little to say about those
things so the trick is to figure out
what he's background ethics he thinks
seem to be fundamental and it comes out
when he makes these claims this
Mississippi white man is my brother this
African okay like okay great but this
guy who hates me is the man I must work
on that's such a powerful idea and that
circumscribing idea that we are co-
Americans is challenging and especially
the past couple months I have to admit
I'm writing the project a little bit
uphill because it's very difficult to to
accept this idea sometimes right
so uh hi I'd like to join the course of
thanking you this was just a beautiful
beautiful talk and I want to say I would
so much rather be thinking about James
Baldwin right now than anything having
to do with Donald Trump so that's you
know a tremendous tremendous uh debt of
gratitude I'd like to speak very briefly
about my own um disciplinary interests
which are
uh anomalously enough Yiddish modernism
if you look at the Yiddish literature
that's being written uh at the time of
uh Baldwin's Early Childhood um there is
a tremendous fascination with the figure
of Jesus and this has a very explicitly
political function I'm sorry I'm sorry I
catch your discipline I apologize um I'm
I'm I'm a yist I say okay got it got I'm
sorry and um so Yiddish writers are
tremendously fascinated by Jesus
uh he's a political figure he is a pgum
victim he is a uh uh someone who is
fighting for Jewish rights you know that
tremendous
reappropriation of Christ out of
Christianity and I'm wondering given how
explicit it seems to me that obviously
Baldwin comes up you know the the church
for Baldwin is a Yeshiva you know he
comes up in a heavily christianized
rhetorical philosophical theological
tradition this suffuses his writing it
saturates his writing is there a similar
gesture not of using Christianity to
liberate black people but to use
Blackness to liberate Christianity
somehow that in a counterintuitive way
actually puts him very proximate to the
role of the church in the Liber struggle
of the 1960s civil rights movement in
other words he's not as far away from
this church that he's trying to
emancipate himself from as he seems to
think that he is no that's that's a a
wonderful point and I think the answer
to that is actually fairly
straightforward yet profound and I
think right I think bald I think a lot
of what Baldwin is up to and many of his
commentary is separating the structures
from the character they're given by the
practitioners right it's not the problem
with democracy it's what people do with
democracy it's not the church it's what
the people do with the church right and
so one way to get the question you're
you're asking is to in some sense um
recognize that I think Baldwin thinks
like a good ethicist if you get the
character of the people right the
institutions they partake in will adjust
to come into right relationship with
virtue and so I think one of the things
you know he never explicitly said it
this way but at least not that I know of
but I think it's perfectly plausible
that if you were to ask Baldwin so what
about this business about the black
church Bal him one way he might respond
is listen if we can get black black
Americans to kind of get into a right
relationship with the idea of love and
the toughness of what it means to be
militant and embracing the problems of
the church fix themselves because what's
happened to the church is the hypocrisy
of the practitioners right the fact that
they go in and go to the mountain this
jubilant dancing it's not a fault of the
church is these people so Desperately
Seeking some form of redemption and and
Escape that cannot be gotten that way
must be got through a tough work of
fighting right the supremacy that that
marginalizes them so all that stuff with
the church that's just a distraction in
some sense from the tougher work but the
dancing and throwing of the arms in the
air this is just a false way of thinking
that one is somehow escaping one's
suffering guess what Monday through
Saturday come back around then next
Sunday you're back here you know jumping
and shouting what happened Monday
through Saturday right the nation was
has been pressing down on you so I think
this is the distinctions he makes I
think it runs all the way way through
you fix the character of the people if
you get them to take up certain kinds of
um right ways of thinking about the
ethics of their lives then these other
institutions come into the right
relationship with them and I think at
that point he has no problem with the
church right I should say one last thing
I think the reason why he never makes
the church the very very center of how
how he argues is that I think he wants
to avoid the situation that I think some
people who are skeptical to the church
might have that is he want people to
feel as if they were thinking for
themselves rather than take and receive
Doctrine right and this accounts a lot
for the rhetorical style that I think
baldon writes in he very rarely tells
you what to think he's always trying to
walk with you and share his
vulnerability I tear up almost every
time I read baldon because I feel as if
he's letting me in somewhere that I'm
not supposed to be and he's asking me to
do the same right and that's a deep
source of personal autonomy in the in
the most profound
sense hi thank you so much um I had a
question about the potential change in
Baldwin's thought over time because um
something that came up in the discussion
of I believe the first of these lectures
was the way in which the critical
consensus has tended to ignore maybe
push aside some of the later works of
Baldwin because um they were too angry
or they were too um one-sided some
things that were were said at the time
almost embarrassing for people who would
like to think of this kind of thought as
an aberation as opposed to another way
you could think about it which is you
know like The Logical fulfillment of
some of the contradictions he was
working through so I was just wondering
if you had thoughts on how you know the
ethics of Love might change into
something like anger whether that fits
into this Paradigm or not so this is a
fantastic question so I'm not sure if
you think of the same thing I'm thinking
about but one of places where I see this
is um the evidence of things not seen
right um and in that book he really
really I don't want to say he seems
defeated that's I think that's true but
something about him seems to have said I
can't believe at this stage of my life
the last project I'm going to do I'm I'm
not sure I can't recall if he he knows
it's the last project but I think he
probably senses it is is study the
murders of 24 young black people which a
black man is being arrested with no
evidence I can't believe this is how you
get that sense you're reading the book
there certain kind of biting bitterness
that he should be doing something
different because America should have
changed and I think this is actually
very instructional because I think what
one thing bald was always kind of honest
about especially when he spoke about
stokeley or the next generation was that
as we experience more of life it is also
within our power to also be to part of
loving ourselves is to not pigeon hole
ourselves into some kind of flat affect
no matter what part of honoring our our
feelings is recognizing the sources of
the bitterness without necessar let him
take us over one way we know it doesn't
take him over is you read his last
interview right with Stud Circle and the
idea there is he tells you know he
basically says look my my job as a
writer has been to be a
witness and as for any human slh
humanist witnessing what baldman has
witnessed being the voice of the people
to America I think took its toll and I
think one of the great things about
reading baldman all the way through his
careers seeing how when a person is
honest about the weight and harms
thinking about the American condition
imposes this is what it can do to a
person so one way of reading all of
Baldwin's Corpus is as a kind of
metaethical um warning sign as to what
this does to people who are honest about
their feelings of what it means to live
in America and consistently face right
the vagaries of racism so this is a
fantastic Point thank
you
thank you as well um there are so many
things wonderful things to think about
here and what you just said reminds me
of something that all the way through
your talk I kept hearing about self-love
as well as love and
I'm I'm compelled to ask about the qu
the difference between someone who is
being kept from loving themselves by
what you called innocence which I is not
so innocent it's a naive Tay it's a a
lack of understanding a lack of
questioning that should be done and
someone who is kept from self-love
because they're constantly bombarded in
other words what Baldwin seems to be
doing is elevating white people who
should criticize them more criticize
them themselves more whereas he
is trying to elevate in a different way
people who don't deserve that kind of
bombardment I'd love you to talk about
that no this this this is right I mean
one of the things that's absolutely
beautiful and bold one that I think
depending on on your political
disposition you might find you might be
impatient with but there is a beauty to
it is that he thought everyone was
suffering now he didn't think that them
and everybody should right should get
off the hook but he thought everyone was
suffering I think as ethical question he
thought that there was no real way for
white Americans to come into a right
relationship with social justice unless
they realized their responsib
but what's important I think as an
ethicist is that the idea of
responsibility is part and parcel of
love because when we love ourselves we
accept our full capacities as persons
capable of freedom and when you're free
you're also free to be responsible right
so that's on the one side and we thought
black with black folks was the problem
with self-love was what happened to his
father and what baldman resented about
his father it wasn't that he was
unsympathetic to right wasn't that he
was unsympathetic to what his father had
suffered is that he thought no matter
what we still have to get on with the
business of living right to not get on
the business of living even given the
things we suffer is to give up the only
thing that we have right and so one so
the idea of self- L releast for blacks
wasn't Redemption as it might have been
for whites it was salvation right um and
these things but you put Redemption
salvation together and I think I'm I'm
over I'm grossly simplifying but you get
Redemption and salvation together and
you get something close to justice for
all and I think this was the idea
hey uh nice to see how you doing um so
throughout your talk uh you talked about
the ethics of self-love in relation to
uh racism and the effects that it had on
both him personally and his father um
and something that I was wondering about
uh when I was thinking about like
decency and indecency and the idea of
loving yourself and loving your kin in
particular was uh the idea of queerness
and Blackness
intersecting um and how even in this
time queerness was something that within
the black community um and larger
society in general um uh was something
that was not loved and was something
that was often hidden um so I was
wondering if you could speak at all um
to whether you think that his ethic of
love for like Americans in general was
motivated by any of these intersections
or um what you think if any connections
there might be no thank you for that's a
great question so I I think there are
two parts that I question but I think
the answer I'm about to give is
exhaustive of the of how you could dice
the question up so I think one thing to
think about is that it definitely
mattered for Baldwin because he had he
had he had um struggled with this for
for for himself throughout his whole
life and he was always a person in touch
with his own feelings and struggles
right so I think even when he wasn't
making an explicit point about right
struggle over queerness in America I
think it's it's it's there and one
reason why I think we know it's there is
because I think for Baldwin the idea of
America wasn't oh it's right America for
Just Right blacks and whites and some
other Brown groups and and then they
have rights I think the commitment to
America as de as Democratic idea was
very fundamental and that he took
seriously the idea that all persons all
humans were to be treated as such as
humans right and I think that most
certainly extended right two concerns
and considerations over queerness we
also know that through some of his
especially through his novels right like
giovan's room part of what he's trying
to really explore is what it meant right
not only as an American but what it
meant as as a person in a society in
which
maybe expressing himself in the way that
he genuinely wanted to um was a real
struggle right and so in a novel like
that he's also trying to come to grips
with right not only country but also
time right where we are in history so I
think he was most certainly attentive to
it um I think that sometimes that
concern get subsumed his especially his
non-fiction writing under the category
of what it means to treat people as
worth worth as due respect in a society
in a Democratic
Society uh thank you for the talk uh my
question was just I guess about the
challenges of an ethics of love and You'
already talked about it from a bunch of
different angles uh so this is kind of
just an attempt I think to ask for
further clarification on the first
question question um and I guess I want
to ask it by way of an
anecdote the line of poetry that stuck
out my head while you were giving your
talk was one from wh ain's uh which
which is it's either the elergy to to
Yates or uh September 1939 when he says
we must love one another or die um but
he took that out of his later poems he
sort of erased it from his Cannon
because he thought it was false uh
both because it's like literally false
we have to love each other and die we
can't escape death but also because I
think he started to think that uh you
know whereas I can postulate the Dignity
of everyone universally I can't
psychologically love everyone so it
impedes a kind of Universalist ethics um
and maybe also uh through the experience
of World War II he started to associate
love with non-moral virtues like loyalty
or solidity and I guess my question
ultimately is what's the relationship
between love and those sorts of nonmoral
Virtues like loyalty or solidarity um
and if you think of it as either being
like those or risking becoming like
those and turning into something like uh
sort of dubious love of nation or
something uh is that problematic so I
guess my question is how do you respond
to you know aging Auden um no so
um so the first thing I have to say
is I'm not sure what to make quite of
the idea that loyalty and solidarity are
non-moral virtues and the reason why I
have a hard time kind of conceiving of
that is I can see in one way while
people say well that's not really those
aren't really moral ideals but on the
other hand if we're not speaking in a
purely abstract sense they're deeply
ethical right ideals about how it is
we're supposed to um dispose ourselves
to other people and when when are we ask
a question but how do I dispose myself
to other people we're asking a moral
question so I so the first thing I want
to say is I'm going sure I accept those
as nonmoral virtues but let's go ahead
and proceed with the question anyway but
I say that because it actually makes a
difference for how we answer the
question right you know the big the big
you know theme in TV and video games and
comics is are zombies right um and it's
important because right Baldwin used the
word
narcotize very very particularly when he
speaks about right the Loveless person
because the narcotized person is is
alive but not living in the relevant
sense and I think this distinction of
being alive but not living is exactly
the kind of thing Ain was going on about
because if we do not love then we must
die is one way of saying that if we
don't love we deny that distinction
between being alive and living right and
I think one of the ways that Balwin
thinks being one of the ways we unite
unify being alive and living is by by
being very attentive and and and tuned
in to our our disposition to other
people right and so going back to
earlier quote where he say put me next
to the African you will see what I mean
he thought that part of living was
understanding the difficulties of what
it meant to to hold more dear this white
guy from Mississippi or Tennessee or
wherever in America than this African
and part of that is a certain kind of
surprising solidarity right it's a
surprising solidarity because it's
founded on this intersection between
identification at a very high level
identification as being a co-participant
a co-h human in a social scheme than at
a very local level what social scheme
American democracy right and so these
converge and you get something like the
notion of solidarity and what's so
challenging and upholding a Baldwin and
ethics is that the solidarity I think he
wants to counsel us to makes us go out
to the street right and say right Trump
has already been mentioned the despite
the horror of making Breer great again I
have I have to hold these people close I
mean they they are my people right um
and so that's why when you think about
solidarity or loyalty for Baldwin I
think these all Converge on this autum
quote because he thinks that if we're to
do more than just be alive but to also
be among the living we cannot deny our
kin and he says right to Buckley right
these these lonely people who deny their
kin and Balman thought the arrow went
both ways not only from whites to blacks
from blacks to whites it didn't work if
you had inequality in that recognition
and so I think in many ways right
balin's Democratic ethics are consistent
with ain's line he probably would have
wish he probably hadn't Struck it
but okay well unless anybody has one
last question I think we should thank
Professor LeBron for a wonderful talk
and
conversation
thank you all for coming I appreciate
[Music]
it